[Music]
now's the time to make the most amazing
perfect white sauce yes and they're
singing behind this once you've mastered
it it's great for pies soups cauliflower
and cheese and souffles
[Laughter]
[Applause]
even Johnny right thanks melt the butter
okay as that's melting flour in - hi
now the most important part is not
worrying about putting coloring it's the
white sauce you don't color it and flour
right nice pan good leave them in
summary spoon okay what we're trying to
do now we're making a paste
basically like a sort of little sandy
block of butter important pies there
cook it out for 30 seconds though
doesn't taste flowery now look there and
this is the secret everybody worried
about making a white sauce because of
the lumps okay get rid of the spoon get
a whisk okay
you'll be fine okay one third milk in
and this is where it starts to turn to
you like okay one third at a time and
basically we're whisking a nice smooth
paste and what you want okay right next
turd in bring that up to the ball and
whisk vigorously the more you whisk okay
the left lump there are leave your mints
just similar that's good right stop stop
stop stop be up the ball give it a good
whisk
you're it's easy okay no keep the pen
Mikey let's get a plastic handle keep it
nice and flat flat okay keep okay the
heats coming key nicely flat and make
sure okay you whisking vigorously trust
me here we go not with the rich keep it
on the heat good now is gonna start
thickening okay
now but if it doesn't you're not Bob let
that mint simmer there nicely right okay
as it comes back up the vault okay
that's all the milk in and now when the
sauce gets really nice and hot time to
put in the T's but don't put the cheese
in until the mix
yes basically that's nice and smooth now
that's ready for cheese a nice strong
mature cheddar
that's not
mix that in take that off show me
okay dude mean right rich like sauce
okay right cheese in let's do this
together now just keep on lifting the
pan keep the package I don't watch you
right where's the cheese right
did that